[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
coincé pas cool prud'h au mas mijaurée
sainte nitouche garçon manqué allumeuse
aguicheuse frivole [ __ ] [ __ ]
prennez vie facile put
puisque c'est comme ça terroristes
intégristes islamistes danger vigipirate
état d'urgence en prison retourne au
bled et après on ose dire que les femmes
sont contradictoires qu'elles savent pas
ce qu'elles veulent c'est pas qu'on sait
pas ce qu'on veut ce qu'on sait pas ce
que vous voulez ce que vous attendez de
nous et que sans doute vous le savez pas
vous même je parle pas de vous un
personnellement je pars de la société en
général quand j'étais petit j'ai une
grande soeur qui a cinquante plus que
moi et je regardais son corps avec une
certaine envie je sais pas si vous aussi
mesdames
ça vous arrive est de mettre des
chaussettes en boule dans vos soutiens
gorge le temps de prendre forme adulte
mais si vous dire comment j'étais
contente à l'âge de 14 15 ans quand j'ai
enfin eu ce corps de femme mais eu un
changement au moins aussi radicales
c'est celui de regard des autres et pas
que le regard il ya eu ce premier venu
qui a commencé à faire des commentaires
à voix haute sur mon corps en le
tutoyant dans la rue ce deuxième qui a
commencé à faire des drôles de bruits de
bouche en me regardant
[Musique]
un autre qui s'est approché de très près
m'a pris le bras en fait quelque chose
d'extrêmement intrusif et d'
incroyablement infantilisant
paradoxalement c'est au moment où on
devient une femme adulte on a
l'impression qu'on va être prise au
sérieux où on va en imposé c'est là
qu'on est le plus inventif lisez c'est
comme s'il y avait un statut au moins
aussi mineur que celui des enfants c'est
celui de la femme
et plus on est femme plus on a des
attributs de femmes
plus on va subir ça le premier signal
que nous envoie la société qu'on est
devenue une jeune femme
c'était ça alors je fais ça parce qu en
fait l'expression harcèlement de rue
j'en avais juste jamais entendu parler
ni de la part de mes parents ni à
l'école c'est comme s'il y avait une
espèce de cape d'invisibilité sur notre
vécu quotidien
c'était une légende urbaine un secret de
polichinelle
bon bah du coup j'ai continué à faire
avec ça comme si ça faisait partie de ma
vie
puis bon ça nous arrivait à chaque fois
en survie donc c'est que ça doit pas
être si grave
et voilà ça a fait partie de ma vie de
meuf
et puis en 2009 je suis allé voir un
documentaire de patric jean la
domination masculine
ce documentaire donne une vision un peu
panoramique de comment s'organise la
domination patriarcale
ce soir là y'avait le réalisateur patric
jean et il a dit une phrase un peu
bateau dans le débat s'était s'il vous
plaît mesdames
rendez nous service dit nous non ce soir
là j'avais plein d'idées nouvelles qui
se bousculaient dans ma tête et j'ai
décidé de rentrer chez moi à pied pour y
réfléchir
et là il ya un taximan qui a ralenti
juste à côté de moi et qui me fait aller
monte de la fée gratos avec ma toute
petite voix de l'époque j'ai répondu non
merci ça ira c'est bon il a continué à
rouler au ralenti à côté de moi en
faisant allez fais pas ta mijaurée monte
et en fait ce qui est en train de monter
c'était ma colère donc je me suis planté
sur mes jambes je me suis retourné je
lui dis me
monsieur quand une femme dit non c'est
non et je me souviens très bien de sa
réponse était étant moment il ressemble
à quoi à ton cul et il est parti alors
j'ai toujours pas compris sa réponse
mais
le plus important c'était qu'il était
parti et moi ce soir là je suis rentré
chez moi avec des pas de géant
j'avais deux ailes comme ça dans le dos
j'avais l'impression d'avoir entendu ma
voix ma voix d'adultes pour la première
fois non mais des mots ça ne suffit pas
pour faire vivre un concept et pour
qu'on comprenne ce qu'on a vécu pendant
des années il faudra que j'attende
encore 5 en 2014 pour que soit créé le
collectif stop harcèlement de rue et je
sais pas vous mais moi quand j'ai
entendu l'expression harcèlement de rue
pour la première fois je me suis fait
c'était donc ça et c'est là que j'ai
compris à quel point ç'a eu un impact
énorme dans ma vie déjà parce que ça
m'est arrivé de façon assez précoce
donc ça a fait passer des messages très
vite dans ma tête des messages assez
efficace comme pour me dresser en fait
aux règles du patriarcat dans la rue
premier message l'extérieur c'est
dangereux
attention petit chaperon rouge tu ne
peut pas traverser le bois tout seul
donc pour vous dire comment c'était
infantilisant même à l'âge de 25 ans de
30 ans j'étais obligé à la fin d'une
soirée d'aller demander à un mec tu peux
pas me raccompagner steuplé le métro est
quand même à 200 m et il est une heure
du matin on sait pas ce qui peut arriver
deuxième message ton corps en tant que
femme est un problème il va pas arrêter
de te poser de problème être désirable
pour une femme c'est être en danger et
ça tue l'intègre très vite c'est à dire
que si tu ne respecte pas les codes de
beauté de canon qui existent dans la
société si tu es trop gros si tu es
poilus si tu es tu t'habilles pas à la
mode on te fera honte
mais si tu respecte parfaitement toutes
ces règles si tu es parfaitement
désirable avec la tenue qu'il faut la
morphologie qu'il faut l'épilation qu'il
faut est bon on te fera honte quand même
à travers le regard des harceleurs leur
sifflet leur tutoiement leurs répliques
alors je vous passe toutes les règles
tacites en société patriarcale
on ne croque pas une baguette dans la
rue on ne mange pas une banane on ne
s'use pas une glace bref on s'habitue et
en intègre les règles un petit peu tordu
de noir c'est l'heure tout ça ça à mine
de rien des impacts physiques sur notre
corps comme tout harcèlement
le stress l'adrénaline la gestion
physique de la colère de la peur quand
dans la rue on voit un attroupement
d'hommes et qu'on sait pas comment ça va
se passer ça aussi un impact ou des
effets et moraux
le sentiment d'injustice puis juste
après le sentiment d'impuissance
parce que si jamais on répond ça devient
plus violents donc ça en venir un petit
peu la situation donc on finit plus tôt
par se taire et par tracé et puis on
finit aussi par de se dire que c'est
vrai que les femmes sont inférieures
plus faibles la preuve en est face à
notre égal un homme qui a le même âge
que nous voir qui est plus jeune et on
est en situation de vulnérabilité on ne
sait pas comment gérer
et puis ça a des effets politiques en
apprend tout simplement intégrer les
règles du dominant on ne peut pas sortir
dans la rue comment le souhaite il faut
voir c'est selon la tenue qu'on à
l'heure à laquelle on sort du quartier
qu'on décide de traverser etc
et le pire c'est qu'on apprend aussi à
se taire face à l'inadmissible
parce que mine de rien le harceleur va
avoir des mots des insultes sexistes des
gestes des attouchements et on apprend
face à l'intolérable à se taire pour ne
pas envenimer la situation
sauf que quand on apprend à se taire
dans la rue on apprend aussi plus tard
au boulot
si on a affaire à des harceleurs parmi
nos collègues nos supérieurs
hiérarchiques à se taire et accepter
on a déjà été acclimatées à ça même
chose dans le foyer de la part de notre
conjoint par exemple
bon tout ça c'est un petit peu tout ce
que je pouvais vous dire de négatif là
dessus donc maintenant on va passer au
positif parce que je ne sais pas si vous
avez remarqué ces derniers temps les
fameux parle et non seulement elle parle
mais elle parle en coeur et vous pouvez
écrire coeur comme vous le voulez je
sais pas si vous avez été très nombreux
à découvrir déjà le mot sororité
sororité ce lien entre les soeurs c'est
le féminin de fraternité qui lui est
dans le triptyque de la république sur
le fronton de toutes les mairies tout le
monde le connaît depuis sa naissance
et s'il y en a quelques-uns qui n'ont
pas encore entendu ce mot qu'elle ne
culpabilise pas c'est normal c'est pas
votre est connu c'est pas une notion
très promu je dirais même qu'elle est
complètement à contre-courant les femmes
on nous apprend plutôt à nous juger
pire à faire subir à d'autres femmes
les jugements qu'on a nous mêmes subi
pour prendre de la distance de peur
d'être contaminé par ce jugement
ah bah c'est sûr que s'il est sorti
comme ça avec cette robe à 2 heures du
matin faut pas s'étonner qu'ils aient
l'idée d'aller négocier son rôle dans un
film avec un producteur dans sa chambre
d'hôtel même si c'est lui qui vous
invitais là dedans
et oui tous ces jugements on les a tous
subi toutes subi plus tôt mais depuis
c'est quelques jours avec certains
hashtag que vous avez entendu non
seulement les femmes parlent mais
soudain elle entre en empathie avec
elle-même elle donne de la crédibilité à
ce qu'elles ont subi
elle arrive à nommer non pas l'anodin
mais des harcèlements des agressions
sexuelles et des viols
c'est à dire des délits et des crimes
elles nous font voir le regard subjectif
des femmes sur le monde et sur leur vécu
et d'autres femmes apprennent à lire ce
témoignage est à s'y reconnaître
elle se dire mais j'ai vécu exactement
la même chose a identifié que ce
qu'elles ont vécu là aussi c'était pas
que des vie de meuf
c'était bien des harcèlements des
agressions des viols des délits et des
crimes et maintenant qu'on s'est tenu la
main en faisant ça
s'il y avait un seul message que je
voudrais faire passer c'est qu'on ne se
lâchent plus jamais la main via une
philosophe que j'aime beaucoup geneviève
fraisse qui a dit une phrase
l'important dans la domination c'est
l'illisibilité de la domination
c'est à dire que la cape d'invisibilité
que j'ai j'ai parlé tout à l'heure elle
n'a pas été posée là par hasard tant que
chacune de nous témoigne chacune de son
côté en gigotant sous la cape
d'invisibilité
c'est très facile de jeter le discrédit
sur elle et les isoler nos mails c'est
une mythos est connue elle est
complètement folle en ondes le sait well
elle se venge de son ex mais quand on se
tient la main il faut vraiment nous
imaginer comme des antennes connectés et
ben le courant passe le message les plus
brouillé le message est clair il est
lisible on nous croit en ce sens notre
force
en ce sens notre crédibilité alors comme
je vous l'aï dit tout à l'heure la
sororité c'est pas une notion très
simple on nous a plutôt appris justement
à nous diviser et je pense que la
première chose à se dire c'est qu'on
devrait apprendre à s'aimer à s'estimer
nous mêmes les femmes c'est metz estimé
est hautement politique quand on est une
femme on nous a appris le contraire on
nous a plutôt appris les complexes
d'infériorité
le complexe d'illégitimité et puis il
faut apprendre à se parler et à échanger
entre nous rien que le fait de survivre
au jour le jour dans une société
patriarcale ça fait tout de nous des
héroïnes
ça fait tout de nous des warriors rien
que le fait de traverser l'espace public
d'un point a à un point b en ayant évité
harceleur demain aux fesses 1 1 06 c'est
comme si on était toutes des experts en
géopolitique
[Musique]
mais comme cette expertise au pot commun
parlons nous les femmes et là encore je
n'invente rien quand je dis soyons soeur
pour ne plus être seul il y avait déjà
un hymne dans les années soixante dix du
mouvement de libération des femmes qui
le disaient seuls dans notre malheur les
femmes l'une de l'autre ignorer ils nous
ont divisé les femmes et de nos soeurs
séparer le temps de la colère les femmes
notre temps est arrivé connaissons notre
force les femmes
découvrons nous des milliers
reconnaissants nous les femmes parlons
nous regardons nous ensemble en nous
opprime les femmes ensemble
révoltons nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]